long des pourparlers sont en cours entre
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan erevan accuse
bafoue d'avoir déployé des hommes sur
son territoire le premier ministre
arménien nikol pashinian annoncé saisir
une alliance militaire régional dominé
par la russie moscou qui appelle au
respect scrupuleux plus c'était le feu
en france emmanuel macron demande le
retrait immédiat des troupes
d'azerbaïdjan et la guyane se
recombinent pour deux semaines alors que
la situation sanitaire s'améliore en
métropole ce territoire ultramarin subit
la pression des mutations du coronavirus
au royaume uni c'est le vario indien qui
inquiète les autorités le nombre de cas
a plus que doublé en une semaine
du côté des états unis les personnes
vaccinées n'ont désormais plus besoin de
porter un masque
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rtl france
les manifestations de colère du vendredi
à travers la cisjordanie ont entraîné la
mort de dix palestiniens et blessé plus
de 150 manifestants selon le ministère
palestinien de la santé le
croissant-rouge nouveaux feront donc
dans ce conflit qui oppose israéliens et
palestiniens depuis lundi il a fait plus
de 100 morts dans la bande de gaza ça
allait les forces du hamas tu
s'affrontent violemment et le premier
ministre israélien benyamin netanyahu
met en garde ce vendredi mais pas encore
fini dit il
le point sur la situation avec françois
xavier lambert les mêmes scènes se
répètent dans le ciel de gaza
signe de l' escalade de la violence des
dizaines de roquettes ont à nouveau été
tirés vers le territoire d'israël
de leur côté des centaines de gazaouis
ont fait leur logement pour se mettre à
l'abri des bombardements israéliens des
forces israéliennes qui ont reçu du
lierre leur étau sur la bande de gaza
les chars et véhicules blindés de tsahal
se sont positionnés tout autour de
l'enclavé palestinienne
les forces de l'état hébreu ont
d'ailleurs annoncé cette nuit la
présence de leurs soldats dans le
territoire avant de se rétracter
mais israël semble se préparer à toute
éventualité
9000 réservistes ont été appelés à se
mobiliser en vue d'une éventuelle
opération terrestre
le premier ministre israélien a lui tenu
à réaffirmer sa détermination à lutter
contre le ramasser ses alliés j'ai dit
que nous ferions payé un prix très lourd
au hamas et aux autres organisations
terroristes et nous continuerons à le
faire avec une grande force nous n'avons
pas dit notre dernier mot et cette
opération se poursuivra aussi longtemps
que nécessaire afin de rétablir le calme
et la sécurité de l'état d'israël
face à la détermination israélienne les
groupes armés gazaouis se disent prêts à
poursuivre les combats
le ramasse a ainsi appelé les compagnies
aériennes à suspendre leurs vols vers
israël les autorités ont d'ailleurs des
routes et les vols vers l'aéroport
international ben gourion de tel aviv
il s'agit de répondre à votre agression
et de revendiquer la victoire pour notre
peuple et nos valeurs sacrées il n'y a
pas de lignes rouges de règles
d'engagement sacré ou de calculs
compliqués la violence qui se répand
également dans les villes israéliennes
où cohabitent et jusqu'à présent
pacifiquement les communautés arabes et
juives
symbole de ces tensions la ville de lod
où des affrontements ont lieu depuis
plusieurs jours au milieu des carcasses
de voitures brûlées les arrestations se
multiplient cette semaine un père de
famille arabe a été tué après avoir été
poursuivi par des extrémistes hier c'est
une synagogue qui a été brûlé pour
tenter de ramener le calme dans ces
villes dites mixtes près de 1000 agents
de la police des frontières ont été
appelés en renfort
et le nu patrouille à la frontière entre
le liban et israël la situation y est
ton dieu blessés par des tirs israéliens
lors d'un rassemblement pour protester
contre les raids israéliens sur gaza
manifestants libanais à ce qu'on vit
aujourd'hui hier qui font plusieurs
roquettes qui ont été tirées du sud du
liban vers israël selon des sources
militaires et de sécurité libanaises les
projectiles ont été lancés à depuis un
secteur proche d'un conte réfugiés
palestiniens l'armée israélienne a
confirmé ces tirs mais affirmé que les
roquettes s'étaient tombés en
méditerranée les raids israéliens contre
gaza ont causé la mort d'une centaine de
personnes ils ont aussi endommagé des
infrastructures des commerces conduisant
de nombreux gazaouis à quitter les lieux
le correspondant de rtl arabique est
allé à la rencontre des habitants de
l'enclavé palestinienne
les commerces de gaza sont bombardés et
les incendies causés par les frappes
israéliennes continuent de détruire des
bâtiments est les forces de défense
civile font tout pour les éteindre
mais les conséquences de cette tragédie
sont là la destruction de la tour al
chourouk mais aussi de magasins aux
alentours
certains tenanciers ont perdu le travail
de toute une vie
la crise dieu coronavirus nous a bien
sûr fait mal comme au reste du monde
nous sommes dans la même situation que
quiconque dans tous les autres pays les
pertes et la paralysie économique à
cause du coronavirus sont partout les
mêmes et nous espérions que pendant la
fête
le seigneur serait miséricordieux envers
nous et envers tout le monde mais les
vents ne soufflent pas comme les navires
le veulent
les affrontements ont commencé cette
tour a été détruite nous avons été
touchés par ces fragments et parlons des
explosions plus de 200 magasins ont été
touchés ceux qui travaillaient se
retrouvent sans ressources elle déjà
responsable de lourdes pertes humaines
ces raids ont également bouleversé la
vie des survivants
cette saison on s'attendait à ce qu'il
soit possible de vendre les produits
disponibles
et puis la guerre est venue on n'a pas
réussi à les vendre ni à faire quoi que
ce soit la zone a été bombardée le
magasin était détruit les marchandises
ont été endommagés le travail s'est
arrêté on ne peut pas travailler on ne
peut pas vendre
donc nous restons ici les bras croisés
il n'y a plus de travail partout à gaza
on peut voir des dizaines d'édifices en
ruine les bombardements tu détruisent
des rues et des infrastructures
les raids israéliens s'intensifie et le
nombre de victimes parmi les
palestiniens n'a de cesse d'augmenter
ici se dressaient des bâtiments
gouvernementaux des maisons des écoles
des fermes des terres des réseaux
d'électricité de distribution d'eau et
d'assainissement
il n'en reste que des ruines cela ne
ressemble pas à une simple escalade mais
plutôt à une guerre qui pourrait encore
s'aggraver et en france emmanuel macron
insiste sur l'urgence d'un retour à la
paix au proche orient ils soulignent le
droit à se rendre à se défendre d'israël
tout en disant sa préoccupation au sujet
des populations civiles à gaza conflit
également suivi de près en russie
vladimir poutine s'est une nouvelle fois
exprimé sur les côtes
je tiens à demander à nos collègues de
s'exprimer sur l'évolution actuelle
de la situation au moyen-orient dont je
parle notamment de l'aggravation du
conflit israélo-palestinien qui se
déroule à proximité immédiate de nos
frontières et affectent directement nos
intérêts en matière de sécurité
nationale faisait des tensions que les
autorités françaises redoutent de voir
s'exporter en france plusieurs dizaines
de personnes se sont réunies hier place
de la république à paris en soutien aux
palestiniens
une autre manifestation est prévue
demain interdite à la demande du
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
à les organisateurs espéraient obtenir
de la justice l'annulation de son
interdiction
le tribunal administratif de paris la
confiance ce soir la préfecture de
police de paris dit craindre des
troubles graves à l'ordre public
considérant qu'il existe un risque
sérieux que les affrontements entre
palestiniens et forces de l'ordre
israéliennes ne se transporte sur le
territoire national et que dans ce
contexte de fortes tensions
cette manifestation soit l'occasion de
troubles graves à l'ordre public entre
partisans de l'une ou l'autre des
parties du conflit à l'arménie j'accuse
l'azerbaïdjan de violations frontalière
revan reproche à bas coûts ne s'être
infiltrés sur son sol le premier
ministre arménien nikol pashinian a
annoncé saisir une alliance militaire
régional dominé par la russie des
pourparlers sont en cours ce vendredi
entre les deux parties amaya souple et
le conflit refait surface entre
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan
ce jeudi le premier ministre nikol
pashinian a accusé l'azerbaïdjan de
violer la frontière arménienne pour
conquérir de nouveaux territoires près
du lac de sève partagé entre les deux
pays
une infiltration subversive selon le
chef du gouvernement arménien par
intérim qui a décidé de saisir
l'organisation du traité de la sécurité
collective
cette alliance militaire régional
prévoit des mesures pour écarter les
menaces qui pèsent sur l'intégrité
territoriale d'un état membre
face à l'avancée des troupes nikol
pashinian à annoncer des manoeuvres
tactiques approprié lors d'un conseil de
sécurité certains groupes de militaires
défunts
armées azéries ont traversé la frontière
de l'arménie et ont voulu faire le siège
du lac sève les forces armées de
l'arménie ont effectué des contres
manoeuvre les azéris stationné dans
certaines régions attenantes ont quitté
les positions prises à la suite des
contres manoeuvres tactiques de nos
forces armées à l'issue d'une évaluation
profonde et exhaustive de la situation
il devient évident que les actions des
azéris sont une provocation mais
l'azerbaïdjan s'est défendu de toute
infiltration sur le territoire arménien
en justifiant ses positions dans des
districts qui lui appartiennent à
l'automne dernier les deux pays se sont
violemment affrontés pour contrôler la
région indépendantiste du haut karabagh
après plus d'un mois de conflit sanglant
qui a fait près de 6000 morts
un cessez le feu avait été signé sous
l'égide de la russie qui continue de
déployer ses soldats pour maintenir la
paix en avril dernier les deux pays se
sont mutuellement accusés d'avoir ouvert
le feu dans l'enclavé contestée à
majorité arménienne
face à ce regain de tension la russie
demande un respect strict du cessez le
feu
non pas qu'il n'y en a pas demandé des
aides
bien sûr la partie arménienne s'est
déclaré extrêmement préoccupé par la
situation à la frontière
cette préoccupation est partagée par le
président poutine comme nous l'avons dit
et le président poutine a souligné la
nécessité de mettre en oeuvre toutes les
dispositions des accords tripartites et
des documents correspondants signé et
surtout la disposition sur la nécessité
d'un cessez le feu tandis que les états
unis prônent une désescalade pacifique
de la situation le président emmanuel
macron s'est de son côté entretenu avec
nikol pashinian ce jeudi pour réitérer
son soutien à erevan et demandé le
retrait des troupes armées
azerbaïdjanaises les forces armées de
l'azerbaïdjan ont pénétré sur le
territoire arménien elles doivent se
retirer immédiatement jeudi une nouvelle
fois au peuple arménien la france est
solidaire
elle le restera l'arménie en conflit
avec l'azerbaïdjan connaît également une
situation intérieure difficile
l'actuel premier ministre par intérim
nikol
lyon a remis sa démission fin avril afin
de permettre l'organisation d'élections
législatives anticipées
celles ci doivent avoir lieu le 20 juin
prochain à la deuxième année de pont des
missions en passe d'être plus mortel que
la première low oms met en garde depuis
fin décembre 2019 locaux vides a fait au
moins 3 millions 300 mille morts dans le
monde
alors que plusieurs pays se des
consignes d'autres comme l'inde
notamment reste aux prises avec une
flambée épidémique dévastatrice
les variants et la progression est
inégale des campagnes de vaccination
inquiète l'organisation mondiale de la
santé appelle ainsi à relancer à
vacciner les enfants et les adolescents
et à faire don des doses libéré au
système kovacs pour les redistribuer aux
pays défavorisés l'écouté je comprends
pourquoi certains pays veulent vacciner
leurs enfants et leurs adolescents mais
je les exhorte à reconsidérer leur
décision et affaires plus tôt donc de
vaccins à kovacs le kobe 19 a déjà coûté
plus de 3 3 millions de vies et nous
sommes en passe de voir la deuxième
année de cette pandémie bien plus mortel
que la première sauver des vies et des
moyens de subsistance
en combinant des mesures de santé
publique et la vaccination et non l'un
ou l'autre est la seule façon de sortir
de la pandémie et pour tenter d'enrayer
l'épidémie landes mise sur
l'accélération de sa campagne de
vaccination elle a été élargie aux 18 44
ans en attendant c'est effet certains
n'hésitent pas à mettre la main à la
pâte pour aider les services de santé
quand un mot clair dans ce commissariat
de la ville d'in d'or située entre
bombay et new delhi
l'agent rachel c'est fini son service
mais sa journée n'est pas terminée
en tant que médecin diplômé
il se rend ensuite à l'hôpital de la
ville dans le but d'aider le personnel
médical en première ligne je suis
capable de gérer les deux fonctions il
n'y a pas de problème en tant que tel
dans l'exercice des deux fonctions parce
que la nature des deux métiers est
différente
et la deuxième chose et que je voulais
faire quelque chose pour les
fonctionnaires de police
donc je coordonne et gère mon temps en
dehors de mes heures de travail à
l'hôpital de la police
[Musique]
beaucoup de collègues de rajesh ont été
touchés par la pandémie
l'homme aux deux métiers a donc souhaité
partager ses connaissances médicales
pour aider les policiers également en
première ligne face au virus
alors que l'un d'eux se retrouvent
débordés par une deuxième vague
surpuissante de covin 19
il n'a donc pas hésité à prêter main
forte à l'hôpital civil de sa ville
comme nous le savons tous la crise du
coc vide travers sa pire phase en inde
donc il ya énormément de policiers qui
souffrent de cette maladie car ils sont
en première ligne
cela me donne envie de faire quelque
chose car je suis médecin en plus d'être
un agent de police
dans le contexte sanitaire actuelle en
inde
l'aide de rajesh permet une meilleure
prise en charge globale des patients
ces derniers sont ravis de l'attention
qui leur est accordée tous les médecins
et leurs aides prennent bien soin de
nous ils font bien attention aux petits
problèmes que nous avons devant nous
nous rétablissons rapidement entre le
poste de police et l'hôpital rage s va
continuer à naviguer jusqu'à ce que la
crise sanitaire s'atténue mais la
situation pourrait bien perdurer depuis
un mois plus de deux cent mille
personnes sont testés positifs chaque
jour dans le pays et en france on de
4400 malades du corps et 19 sont en
réanimation et de son monde devant 3500
à l'hôpital
à quelques jours de la
ouverture des terrasses de restaurants
et des lieux de culture l'épidémie
hercules une zone reste toutefois en
état d' alerte la guyane la situation
sanitaire se dégrade
en un mois le taux d'incidence a plus
que doublé et plus de 80% des malades
sont infectés par le variant brésilien
conséquence un semis confinement est
entrée en vigueur ce vendredi et au
moins jusqu'au 30 mai bars restaurants
et lieux de culture sont fermés
réactions deviennent et xavier
secrétaire général du syndicat union des
travailleurs guyanais plus de prévention
c'est à dire séance en cédant l'analyste
demain l'analyse tout explose ces
contaminations parce qu'elle ne va rien
brésilienne comme tout virus va prendre
le pas sur le virus classique il évolue
ça c'est normal mais derrière les moyens
de prévention autour de cela
c'est à dire de faire l'analyse de
comment où et quand les difficultés en
rencontrant pour pouvoir s'y
reconstruire ce variant et bien voilà
parce qu'on en arrive à quelqu'un qui
avait un bar et un sud africain
en guyane mais on se doute bien qu'il
arrivait par l'arrêt au bois donc ça
veut dire que quelque part on alors il
ya quelque chose à faire
diadème et qui ne sont pas c'est
aujourd'hui une lila rs ni l'arrêt
facture ni le rectorat
ni les autorités locales préconise au
royaume uni c'est le vario indien qui
inquiète les autorités
malgré une large vaccination de la
population et un nombre d'opca quotidien
au plus bas depuis le pic de janvier à
l'émergence de cette mutation du
coronavirus pourrait mettre à mal le
calendrier du déconfinement total en une
semaine les cas en plus que doublé dans
plusieurs villes le vario indien est
devenu la souche dominante
le premier ministre un boris johnson
affirme mettre tout en oeuvre pour
éviter une augmentation de cas au
royaume uni en écoute obi-wan 6 vous
avez raison de soulever que le variant
indiens y les enverrions préoccupant car
nous sommes inquiets à son sujet il
s'est répandu pour l'instant les avis
scientifiques sur rue qui pourrait se
passer sont très divers
mais nous voulons nous assurer que nous
prenons toutes les mesures de prudence
toutes les mesures de précaution que
nous pouvons prendre chose les réunions
se poursuivent donc pour examiner
exactement ce que nous devons faire
nous n'excluons rien bien sûr à win it
does nothing
il est évident qu'il faut procéder à des
tests de dépistage s'assurer que chaque
fois que l'on a on casse on vérifie
toutes les personnes qui ont été en
contact avec cette personne
micron table la poste et du côté des
états unis le vide continue de perdre du
terrain depuis plus d'un mois maintenant
le pays recense moins de mille morts par
jour très loin des records du début
d'année où le seuil des 4000 morts
quotidiens avait été franchi à plusieurs
reprises les nouvelles infections sont
elles aussi en baisse constante avec
moins de cinquante mille cas par jour
depuis une semaine
conséquence les personnes entièrement
d'accéder seront dispensés du port du
masque en intérieur c'est ce qu'a
annoncé le président américain il y à
quelques jeures les centres de
prévention et de lutte contre les
maladies
les cdc ont un sens qui ne reconnaît
plus le port du masque pour les
personnes entièrement vacciner
cette recommandation est valable que
vous soyez en l'intérieur ou à
l'extérieur
je pense que c'est une étape importante
ça un grand jour avec platement vacciner
et que vous pouvez enlever votre masse
vous avez gagné le droit de faire la
chose ça tienne les américains sont
connus partout dans le monde
saluer les autres avec un sourire marc
aux seychelles c'est plus de la moitié
la population qui a été vaccinée 60% des
habitants reçu l'injection du sérum
chinois issus de l'entreprise un
sinopharm pourtant les quelques vides
augmente faux total l'archipel compte
9000 cas positifs pour près de cent
mille habitants
le commissaire à la santé publique a
décidé de s'exprimer
et selon lui deux tiers des seychellois
n'ont pas encore reçu la deuxième
injection l'essai
faire pour être immunisé jusqu'à présent
nous constatons que la plupart des
personnes qui obtiennent un résultat
positif
en fait plus des deux tiers n'ont pas
été complètement vaccinés
certains n'ont jamais été vaccinés en
majorité et quelques zones n'ont pas eu
leur deuxième dose nous enregistrons
cependant quelques cas positifs environ
un tiers des cas positifs sont des
personnes qui ont été vaccinées avec les
2 2 mais ce groupe de personnes a
tendance à ne présenter aucun symptôme
elles ont été testées parce qu'elles
étaient des contacts où elle présente
des symptômes légers
le chili fait un pas de plus vers sa
réforme constitutionnelle le pays et
lice ce week-end et citoyen chargé de
rédiger la future constitution qui
remplacera celle héritée de l'ère
pinochet
à la clé la promesse d'un changement de
système réclamé lors des manifestations
d'octobre 2010 9 solène gaudin une
élection sur toutes les lèvres dans ce
marché de santiago du chili
c'est une excellente occasion pour le
pays de réécrire l'histoire et de
laisser aux générations futures
quelque chose de prosper quelque chose
tout le monde veut c'est bien car notre
constitution est très obsolètes et avait
été créé pour les hommes d'affaires et
les millionnaires pas pour le peuple une
nouvelle constitution pour tourner la
page de célérité de la dictature
militaire d'augusto pinochet
une des revendications portées par le
plus grand soulèvement social de
l'histoire du chili en octobre 2010
fragilisé le gouvernement du président
sebastian pinera a été contraint
d'accepter un référendum sur le
changement de constitution en novembre
2020 le oui l'a emporté à 80% six mois
plus tard la population est appelée ce
samedi et ce dimanche à désigner les
rédacteurs de la nouvelle loi
fondamentale
parmi ses concitoyens à la veille du
rendez vous la campagne bat son plein
dans la capitale chilienne
il faut que cela reste un état qui n'est
pas trop interventionniste je ne dis pas
que le chili doit cesser d'avoir un
système de santé public pas du tout mais
qu'il doit être meilleur et que l'état
ne doit pas dépenser plus qu'il ne peut
pas parce qu'il a été définitivement
démontré sur ce continent que cela
signifie la ruine des pays
par conséquent nous deuxième donc
également éliminer les déchets
conservateur issu de la constitution de
1980 qui ont bloqué bon nombre des
réformes que j'ai voulu promouvoir ces
dernières années
espérons que cette nouvelle constitution
garantira tous les droits de tous les
citoyens pour le bien être de tous nous
avons besoin d'une constitution avec
laquelle ils donneront aux pauvres un
plus grand accès à tout comme plus de
1300 candidats indépendants ou
appartenant à des partis politiques de
droite comme de gauche font campagne
pour décrocher un siège parmi les 155
rédacteur de la nouvelle constitution
la moitié d'entre eux seront des femmes
une première en amérique du sud 17
sièges seront réservés à des
représentants des peuples indigènes un
week end décisif pour écrire un nouveau
chapitre de l'histoire chilienne à
quelques mois d'une autre échéance
cruciale
l'élection présidentielle prévue en
novembre prochain
en pleine fête de l'aïd certaines
communautés musulmanes regrette de ne
pas pouvoir célébrer cette date sacrée
c'est le cas de milliers de yéménites
déplacés par la guerre et qui ont trouvé
refuge dans le gouvernorat de taiz dans
un camp fou la misère est une réalité
ils témoignent de leur tristesse
martial peuvion loin des grandes villes
c'est ici dans ces camps de réfugiés que
vivent des milliers de yéménites
ce jeudi ils n'ont pas pu célébrer comme
il le souhaite l'aïd une défaite majeure
du calendrier musulman
comme vous pouvez le voir c'est
relativement calme gens jettent un jour
comme les autres
les traditions et les célébrations que
nous avions l'habitude d'observer dans
le vide n'existe pas dans ce camp ne
pouvons rien faire pour bien une
situation particulièrement difficile
pour les enfants privés de découvrir les
coutumes mains liées à cette fête
religieuse
aujourd'hui c'est le premier jour de
l'aïd et il n'y a pas d'activité ou de
célébrations dans les camps pas même
pour les enfants certains d'entre eux se
cachent à l'intérieur des tentes parce
qu'ils n'ont pas de nouveaux vêtements
de nouveaux jouets de cadeaux pour l'aïd
ni même de visites de leur famille
que pourrait-on leur offrir nous ne
possédons rien et c'est pour cette
raison qu'il n'ya pas de célébration de
l'aïd
alors que ce camp qui accueille 350
familles accueillent environ 500 enfants
de moins de cinq ans selon le haut
commissariat des nations unies aux
réfugiés le yémen compte quatre millions
de déplacés et cent trente sept mille
réfugiés qui ont fui le conflit qui
ravage le pays
une guerre qui dure depuis 2014 entre le
gouvernement soutenu par l'arabie
saoudite et ses alliés au mouvement
outils appuyé par l'iran
certains habitants gardent espoir et
espère un jour retrouver leur mode de
vie d'antan
j'espère que nous serons dans nos villes
près d'elle cada lors du prochain nahid
pour que nous puissions travailler
nous promener avec vos enfants et leur
faire des cadeaux comme nous le faisions
avant quand l'aï d'approché on se
réjouissait et on se sentait heureux
maintenant l'aïd est là et nous sommes
tristes parce que nous vivons dans des
tentes sous le soleil brûlant et les
vents violents
nous vivons avec ce que nous avons
mercredi le conseil de sécurité de l'onu
a appelé à une cessation immédiate des
hostilités au yémen selon les nations
unies
le pays vit actuellement la pire crise
humanitaire au monde
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain journal à 21h à
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
la repentance est un sentiment aux
conséquences extrêmement graves pour
l'avenir
cette pratique obsessionnel s'impose
dans l'esprit de nos dirigeants comme la
condition incontournable d'une
gouvernance responsable moderne plutôt
que de se repentir
on ferait mieux de faire référence un
peu